es gibt nur eine frage von belang
schwört ihr bei eurem leben
die wahrheit zu sagen diese woche geht
es um last von ridley scott der ist ja
normalerweise bekannt für solche großen
science fiction abenteuer wie alien oder
blade runner hat auch ein paar
historische sachen gemacht in seiner
karriere gladiator zum beispiel oder
auch exodus sie sind mal mehr mal
weniger gelungen und hier in führte uns
diesmal wieder in etwas historisches
nämlich ins paris des vierzehnten
jahrhunderts an den französischen hof wo
das letzte duell wird es in titel schon
heißt stattfindet
mein vater sagte mir mein leben wird mit
glück gesegnet sein worum gehe jetzt das
ist gar nicht so einfach zu sagen denn
scott hat sich eine geschichte
vorgenommen die mehrere protagonisten
hat und jeder hat seine eigene
sichtweise darauf und er hat sich auch
vorgenommen jede dieser sichtweisen zu
erzählen es geht damit los dass zwei
ritter aufeinandertreffen einer gespielt
von matt damon einer gespielt von dem
driver könnten beide unterschiedlicher
nicht sein mit dem man kommt als sohn
eines guten daher der einige ländereien
hat aber nicht besonders viel geld und
deshalb auf kreuz zu begehen muss dem
driver komplett mittellos hat sich an
einem fürsten rangegangen sozusagen der
fürst wird gespielt von ben affleck ist
es wirklich wunderschöne sprache
starbesetzung und irgendwann wird etwa
ein auge auf die frau von matt damon
werfen und daran entzündet sich
sozusagen das ganze drama das dann am
ende zu diesem duell führt was wir
gleich am anfang präsentiert bekommen du
wirst es mit mir geschieht verlierst du
das 3
du wusstest es und sagt es nur nicht
straff pflicht jene die die wahrheit
sagen und
das unseres kindes ist nicht abhängig
von gottes wegen
viel mehr davon ich halte man zuerst
ermüdet interessant ist dass gott sich
hier eine erzählform genommen hat die
wir in den 50er jahren erst mal gesehen
haben bei akira kurosawa also das heißt
es gibt einen film der heißt raschem on
19 50 rausgekommen auf deutsch glaube
ich der titel das lust welchen was viel
frivoler klingt als der film eigentlich
ist da geht es um ein samurai der
getötet wurde mehrere menschen sind in
diesem wald gewesen jeder davon erzählt
die geschichte wie dieser samurai ums
leben gekommen ist jeder will daran
schuld gewesen sein es geht um ehre es
geht um ruhm und man bekommt das so aus
diesen ganzen verschiedenen perspektiven
erzählt es gott macht das ähnlich nur
dass er eben nicht in japanischen
ehrenkodex und sondern sich der kodex
des französischen mittelalters zur
vorlage nimmt wo beispielsweise eine
frau besitzt um eines mannes ist das
heißt ein übergriff auf eine frau
übergriff auf den besitz des mannes ist
was irgendwie ihren verletzend ist und
deswegen geahndet werden muss und er
gibt jeder dieser figuren genau so viel
raum wie große aber das auch getan hat
also das heißt wir sehen auch hier
szenen wiederholen sich sehen aber
völlig anders aus und man muss es sich
sozusagen selber zusammenpuzzeln wer die
wahrheit sagt ich bin wie das ganze
eskaliert und was das eigentlich für ein
system ist was leute dahin bringt am
ende auf einem schlachtfeld auf einem
auf einem hergerichteten schauplatz
gegeneinander anzutreten vor großem
publikum auf und auf leben und tod zu
kämpfen um die wahrheit herauszufinden
wie kannst du so mit mir zu sprechen
ich erzählte einen anderen weg und jetzt
werde ich womöglich verpackt ich
riskiere mein leben für dich
auch erst
und ich deinem feind zu steigen und
einen
wirklich gott ist ja für seine ganzen
bildgewaltigen ideen bekannt und das
setzte auch hier durch also das heißt
dadurch dass wir eben ein ritter
geschichte haben die wir hier erzählt
bekommen dadurch dass es aus
verschiedenen perspektiven einmal aus
der perspektive von matt damon der
wirklich dieser ich gehe auch feldzüge
und trete hier in schlachten gegen
andere lehre an so ein typ ritter ist
sozusagen der sich damit seinen
lebensunterhalt verdienen muss gibt es
jede menge schlacht ziehen es gibt eine
ganz tolle wo er wo sein ganzer
charakter sich eigentlich zeigt wo er in
hagel von brennenden teilen auf einem
feld in schottland steht und alle
anderen hinter ihm schon die flucht
ergreifen und er sich nur verwundert
umdreht und sagt warum fliegt ihr und
anfängt alle in die schlacht zu führen m
driver's ganze erzählung ist einem ganz
anderen licht gehalten auch also dass es
viel viel wärmer vielmehr in innenräumen
vielmehr diese dieser charakter der
wirklich sich darauf verlegt hat per
höfischer intrigiert seine karriere
machen und die dritte perspektive aus
sicht der frau hat ebenfalls noch mal
eine komplett andere qualität bei dem
driver beispielsweise haben ja kurzen
moment wohl so eine traumsequenz drin
ist das ist nicht ganz klar die mit
einer wackelkamera mit so ein bisschen
verkriechen handkamera bild aufgenommen
ist also das heißt es gibt jeweils
unterschiedliche stilmittel auch die
einem die unterschiedlichen perspektiven
erzielen mehr noch die person irgendwie
einem nahe bringen über über diese
filmischen mittel ist sehr
unterschiedliche jeder eigentlich für
jeden was dabei also das heißt wer der
sollte in diesem film gehen alle die
irgendwie spaß haben an so großen
historien sachen die bildgewaltig
daherkommen die man das kino erschlägt
weil es sollten sich auch alle angucken
die es ist sowieso lieben wenn matt
damon und ben affleck zusammen vor der
kamera stehen und sich so ein bisschen
an bitten möchte man sagen denn die
beiden sind sowieso schon gute
schauspieler aber wenn sie zusammen in
einem film sind hat das noch eine
komplett andere qualität also das heißt
sie ziehen sich immer so ein stück weit
gegenseitig hoch die probieren sich dann
immer gegenseitig so ein bisschen noch
zu übertrumpfen in ihrem können und das
ist wirklich wahnsinnig unterhaltsam
hier zumal ben affleck die schönsten kuh
ersten klamotten anhalt ich man sich im
französischen mittelalter so vorstellen
konnte also es ist wirklich wahnsinnig
schöne garderobe und man sollte das
diesem film vor allen dingen mit
mehreren personen im kino ansehen denn
was ich festgestellt habe als ich das in
venedig beim filmfestival mir angesehen
habe danach kommen alle raus und haben
eine unterschiedliche sichtweise drauf
was eigentlich passiert ist oder sie
haben unterschiedlichen blick darauf
welche personen jetzt eigentlich gut ist
oder besonders stark war oder besonders
überzeugend rüber kam also das heißt
ridley scott schafft hier durch die
verschiedenen perspektiven
verschiedenen zuschauern auch
andockpunkte zu geben für wen man ist
wem man glaubt was man überzeugen da
findet und das wirklich dann zu
diskutieren er hat dadurch aber auch
gerade weil er zwar wahrheiten
präsentiert aber verschiedene
sichtweisen auf die wahrheit präsentiert
und sehr modernen sehr sehr zeitgemäßen
film gemacht eben weil wir gerade in
einer zeit sind wo
nicht alle sich auf unterschiedliche
ebenen begeben wenn es um wahrheit gibt
also sich verschiedene seiten anzuhören
erfordert ja heutzutage für einige schon
eine herausforderung das ist ja schon
etwas was die meisten gar nicht mehr
imstande sind zu tun von daher ein sehr
sehr interessanter sehr anregend dafür
über die man unbedingt mit mehreren
personen reden möchte danach
euro strafe für das ablegen sollten sich
ist das ihr verbrannt werden bei
lebendigem leib ich werde nicht
schweigen
[Musik]
ist die uhr